statement of results at the conclusion
of the count the North East Somerset
constituency as the acting returning
officer for the election to the
parliamentary constituency of North East
Somerset on Thursday the 8th of June
2017 I hereby certify that the total
number of ballot papers at the
conclusion of this camp is 53147 the
turnout instances Citroen C is seventy
five point 88 percent the total number
of votes given for each of the
candidates is as follows car Valley
Sarah
Claire Roth Green Party 1245
[Music]
[Applause]
Hugh Hughes Shawn independent 588 Ross
Robin Labour Party 18,000 757
resmoke Jacob William the Conservative
Party candidate 28,000 992 Rigby Mandor
Liberal Democrats 4461 the total number
of it's respectable thousand and forty
three the number of ballot papers
rejected at the count is as follows once
an official not one voting for more than
one candidate twenty two voting writing
or mark by which the voter could be
identified two and unmarked or void from
certainty 79 the total number of
rejected ballot members are one hundred
and four meters I thereby declare that
Jacob William Reece logs has been duly
elected well ladies and gentlemen may I
begin by tak thanking the acting
returning officer we are considerably
earlier than we laughed well last time
this has been a model of an efficiently
run count so thank you to her and her
team but a great thank you to my fellow
candidates the tone of this campaign in
North East Somerset has been one of
strong competitiveness but friendliness
I particularly like to thank Robin for
the Labour Party's campaign which was
done in a very different spirit from
before and I notice a better spirit of
campaign put his boat up so I hope if he
stands again he probably gets back from
bad spirit because he was very good for
him this time and Mandy who told me she
herself she's taken my seat which is
very splendid and we had a really good
tempered campaign and Sally from the
greens and an independent candidate it's
hard to stand an independent candidate
and shows a real commitment to local
so I want to say thank you to all of
them to my terrific team my agent
Margaret Brewer my family who played a
leading part in this campaign indeed I'm
borrowing my son's rosette which is even
bigger than my own and just to make it
clear that I am the Conservative Party
candidate so everybody who worked and
helped get me re-elected it has been a
most fascinating sefa logical evening
for us with results coming in from all
over the country of a most unexpected
kind the conservative and unionists
doing very well in Scotland but less
well in London we will be able to pour
over this tomorrow morning as we go
through all the newspapers and all the
intricacies of the results but tonight
it's an opportunity just to say thank
you and say what a real honor it is to
have the opportunity to continue to
serve other people of North East
Somerset and for the vote of confidence
they have given to me personally out of
the Conservative Party and to allow me
to do that it is a real privilege and I
will do my best to live up to their
expectations so thank you all very much
indeed
[Applause]
like to act thank the acting returning
officer the police and staff for a very
well conducted and as Jacob said under
Lee finish to this evening I'd also like
to thank and especially thank my
wonderful team from a standing start
when the election was surprisingly
announced twenty five weeks ago the
inspiring passionate energetic way that
they have run this campaign has been
made it an honor and a privilege to be
the Labour Party candidate and I think
we can be proud of the results we have
achieved from from from where we were a
couple of years ago would like to
mention names but there are just too
many and of course you miss somebody out
if you do that I'd also like to thank my
fellow candidates I think as as Jacob
referred to we very deliberately
concentrated on the policies and the
differences in the different vision of
the UK that that we have and the debates
and and all the and all the discussion
was around that particularly like to
thank manda and and Sally I know that
their vote is looking quite low in this
election but that is very clearly
because with a first-past-the-post
election in a multiparty democracy I
know that many greens and many live Dems
decided to lend their labour their votes
and I have to say look forward to seeing
you on again in October I guess
because the election that didn't have to
be called in order for strong and stable
government has blown up spectacularly in
the Conservatives faces it will be
interesting to see where the next few
months go but all I can say is when the
election comes in a few months time you
won't better spring a surprise on this
next time we will be ready and be
prepared and we will get a different
result so this is the election of 2017
but probably some lights 1974 it'll end
up historically being the June in the
election of 2000 2017 because I don't
think we've seen the end of political
campaigning this year finally and last
anot but not least I said I wouldn't
mention any names but I have to thank my
wife Angie yes it's if we have a claim
it's tough to be a candidate aside to
imagine it's even tougher to to have to
live with